[Music]
radiate boundless love towards the
entire world
a disciplined mind brings happiness
give even if you have only a little
conquer anger with love
conquer badness with goodness
conquer meanness with generosity
conquer dishonesty with truth
drop by drop the water pot is filled
likewise the wise man gathering little
by little fills himself with good
[Music]
i will not look on another's bold intent
of finding fault
a training to be observed
delight in heedfulness
guard well your thoughts
should you find a wise critic to point
out your faults
follow him as you would a guide to
hidden treasure
should a seeker not find a companion who
is better or equal let him resolutely
pursue a solitary course
in whom there is no sympathy for living
beings
know him as an outcast
hatred is never appeased by hatred in
this world by non-hatred alone is hatred
appeased
this is a law eternal
live with no sense of mind
not forming attachment to experiences
[Music]
all conditioned things are impermanent
when one sees this with wisdom
one turns away from
suffering ardently do today what must be
done who knows tomorrow death may come
to support mother and father to cherish
wife and children and to be engaged in
peaceful occupation
this is the greatest blessing
all tremble at violence all fear death
putting oneself in the place of another
one should not kill or cause another to
kill
they blame those who remain silent they
blame those who speak much
they blame those who speak in moderation
there is none in this world who is not
blamed
just as the great ocean has one taste
the taste of salt so also this teaching
and discipline has one taste the taste
of liberation
if with a pure mind a person speaks or
acts
happiness follows them like a never
departing shadow
as an elephant in the battlefield
withstands arrows shot from bows all
around
even so shall i endure abuse
the root of suffering is attachment
whatever precious jew there is in the
heavenly worlds
there is nothing comparable to one who
is awakened
it is in the nature of things that joy
arises in a person free from remorse
[Music]
purity and impurity depend on oneself
no one can purify another
[Music]
ceasing to do evil cultivating the good
purifying the heart
this is the teaching of the buddhas
understanding is the heartwood of
well-spoken words
[Music]
just as a solid rock is not shaken by
the storm
even so the wise are not affected by
praise or blame
[Music]
we will develop love we will practice it
we will make it both a way and a basis
there is no fear for one whose mind is
not filled with desire
whatever is not yours let go of it
you're letting go of it will be for your
long-term happiness and benefit
[Music]
meditate do not delay lest you later
regret it
whatever can arise can cease
your own self is your master who else
could be
with yourself well controlled you gain a
master very hard to find
[Music]
your work is to discover your work and
then with all your heart to give
yourself to it
[Music]
i do not dispute with the world rather
it is the world that disputes with me
you cannot travel the path until you
have become the path itself
do not dwell in the past do not dream of
the future
concentrate the mind on the present
moment
if we could see clearly the miracle of a
single flower
our whole life would change
the only real failure in life is not to
be true to the best one knows
[Music]
be truthful do not yield to anger give
freely even if you have but little
the gods will bless you
the whole secret of existence is to have
no fear
never fear what will become of you
depend on no one
only at the moment you reject all help
are you free
if anything is worth doing
it is worth doing with all your heart
when you attain victory over yourself
not even the gods can turn it into
defeat
[Music]
better than a thousand hollow words is
one word that brings peace
[Music]
what we think
we become
if you do not change direction you may
end up where you are heading
nothing can harm you as much as your own
unguarded thoughts
nothing remains without change
one moment can change a day
one day can change your life
one life can change a world
faith and prayer are invisible but they
make impossible things possible
with mindfulness strive on
if the problem can be solved why worry
if the problem cannot be solved worrying
will not help you solve it
you must love yourself before you love
another by accepting yourself and fully
being who you are
your simple presence can make others
happy
everything that happens to us is the
result of what we ourselves have thought
said or done
we alone are responsible for our lives
[Music]
love the whole world as a mother loves
her only child
[Music]
health is the greatest gift contentment
is the greatest wealth
it is better to do nothing than to do
what is wrong
whatever you do
you do to yourself
[Music]
work out your own salvation
do not depend on others
do not look for a sanctuary in anyone
but yourself
no one saves us but ourselves no one can
and no one may
we ourselves must walk the path
[Music]
if we fail to look after others when
they need help who will look after us
one who acts on truth is happy in this
world and beyond
wear your ego like a loose-fitting
garment
[Music]
when watching after yourself you watch
after others
when watching after others you watch
after yourself
the greatest gift is to give people your
enlightenment to share it
ambition is like love impatient both of
delays and of rivals
[Music]
you as much as anybody in the entire
universe deserve your love and affection
if you propose to speak always ask
yourself is it true
is it necessary is it kind
[Music]
every human being is the author of his
own health or disease
the tongue like a sharp knife kills
without drawing blood
the way is not in the sky it is in the
heart
if you truly loved yourself you would
never hurt another
every morning we are born again
what we do today is what matters most
nothing ever exists entirely alone
everything is related to everything else
[Music]
you